today I want to encourage you to set
bigger goals for yourself so I've always
been a fan of setting goals for myself I
find that it pushes me towards action it
makes me work a little bit harder it
stretches me to do more for the past I
want to say two years my my goal has
been to be the number one youtuber at my
agency my bigger goal my meta goal has
always been to help a billion
entrepreneurs but that's a huge goal
that's not something that's happening in
the next year and so I like having
shorter term still big goals to push me
and so that go really helped me that
goal made me push a little harder maybe
bring on a team made me think more
strategically it just pushed me to want
to be number one and I hit that goal a
couple months ago I want to say and
since then I haven't had a new kind of
big goal to push me I've got you know
130 something thousand subscribers on
the channel which is awesome and the
next goal you know it could be 200,000
could be 500,000 doesn't feel really
motivating for me you know i don't know
500,000 subscribers is a great number
but doesn't feel like a huge thing for
me i don't know why the next one in my
head is a million i wanna hit in lynn
subscribers and I look at my current
rate and I'm getting 15 to 20,000
subscribers a month and feel like the
million mark is just too far away to get
excited about it you know my current
pace of growth would be you know five
years before I hit a million subscribers
I don't want to wait that long you know
I want something a little more
short-term that I can get behind and get
excited about and this morning I was
meeting with somebody in giving her some
advice and talking about her directly in
her life encouraging her to think bigger
and I thought back to advice I gave
somebody else and I gave you guys a
couple time to think about taking your
five-year goals and making them into a
one year goal right start now stop
planning stop wishing one day actually
do it right now and Here I am sitting on
a potential five-year goal and thought
you know what I got to take my own
advice take
got five year goal of a million
subscribers and make it one year and we
may not hidden in one year but just
having that mentality forces me to make
different decisions forces me to think
bigger yes I won't hit a million
subscribers in a year doing what I'm
doing now because my current rate of
growth shows that but I have to do
something else and it forces me to start
thinking okay now that's the goal what
do I have to do to accomplish that goal
now I'm not a hundred percent sold on it
I think I'm gonna sleep on a couple
nights but I'm leaning more and more and
more in that direction and so how does
this relate to my book not directly with
the YouTube goal but as an example with
the book my agent said in the first year
a really good book in this category will
sell 50 to 100,000 copies before that I
had no idea what makes the best sellers
the 5,000 copies is that 500,000 copies
I didn't know what was the benchmark for
success and just knowing that the
benchmark for a really good book in his
first year is fifty to a hundred
thousand copies that gives me a goal and
once the book comes out that's what I'll
be chasing and hopefully past that
because i like to overachieve whenever
possible so I think it's really
important to have big goals that
motivate you that not just something
that you know you can do you know said
as a stretch goal Senate is something
that forces you to think differently
forces you to ask okay well if I was
going to do this how would I do it and
it makes you change your approach it
makes you question your thinking it
makes you make bigger decisions and more
important decisions that change your
business and so I'm curious for you guys
in the comments what a good big goal
stretch is for you for the next 12
months leave in the comments below
really curious to find out okay on to
the questions now as usual we have one
week with very few questions and then I
call you guys out and then you leave an
insane number of questions so this week
lots of questions we'll try to get
through them quickly number one Tamara
weeks fun video Jen great to see you in
Evans videos were you nervous meeting
happen for the first time and also
making a video with him Evan what will
you replace your book-writing time with
I mean Nebraska come on down the
Cornhusker state so she's referencing
last week's video I was in Seattle I met
up with Jenn who's helping me write the
book and
drove up from Portland two and a half
hour three hour drive to get there and
join me on the videos I hope she wasn't
super nervous I don't know she'll have
to answer that question herself we've
talked a lot especially on google
hangouts invite email and I feel like I
know her already as a friend so for me
it was it was fine i was exciting it was
great to be able to do some cloud videos
together in person but we'll see what
she says see me she was nervous I don't
know in terms of what's going to happen
with my book writing time I honestly
don't know right now right now I planned
out my tuesday so today's Tuesday
recording this video as my content
creation day if I'm not writing the book
then I'm probably doing other content
creation things people want me to create
courses for them I might plan out
special videos I might write for the
website I don't know you know that's the
plan at least for now once we get into
January and the book is pretty much done
and over the publishers hands I'll see
honestly I'll see but right now that's
kind of the plan is to have content
creation day be Tuesday Eddie rights I'm
in Sydney Australia I understand if you
don't want to come down here yeah last
week I talked about where you guys from
where should i do a potential book tour
I love Australia I've never been but I
want to go I love the people I love the
weather I love the culture my sister
went there for her honeymoon and spent a
month and so it's on my list if I can
throw an excuse to get there with my
book tour then I will gladly do it next
up Devon I can't wait to read the book
thanks bro I'm looking for a writer to
collab on a movie script and sitcom idea
this is a cool opportunity one thing
that I know is right now because I know
you're an actor because I know you're
trying to make it if I ever had a need
for an actor you'd be the first guy that
I connect with because i know you you're
part of the community and I know what
you're all about and so I think there's
tons of potential collaborations for you
there's tons of riders is tons of
directors as tons of producers looking
for actors to do collaborations with
they just have to know you and I think
the key thing is starting to hang out
where they hang out and that's offline
and on
right you're hanging out in my community
I see you on periscope I see you on
YouTube you're sharing and tweeting my
stuff I super appreciate it it's super
windy here I hope that's not too bad on
the audio for you guys and so you be top
of my list if I needed an octave or
something you want to do that same thing
for people who you can have solid
collaborations with right with writers
with producers with film directors all
of those guys hang out where they hang
out online and offline make sure you're
a known quantity big ass truck going by
they should know your name and then
you'll be first in line for any
collaboration opportunities next up new
future builder awesome answer Evan thank
you love how we keep pushing you to
answer questions about the book without
revealing it hot good look topic is
still a secret for now I've dropped a
few hints for those loyal viewers you
may picked up on a couple of them will
get there we'll get there building
curiosity and also I don't want too much
to come out before we actually launched
it so hang in there hang in there happy
to answer questions as much as I can and
still build the curiosity up next up
Adrian and William I'm in fairfield
california bring jen with UK william
come to New York City not sure exactly
where fairfield california is but if i
do a book tour I'm sure california and
new york will be on the list two of my
favorite spots in America so I'm excited
to come in and meeting you guys one
other tip for all you non Torontonians
watching which is most of you every time
I go away on a trip I always email
people on my list we're in that city and
say hey guys I'm here do you want to
meet up you want to grab a coffee my
schedule is usually pretty tight but I
can usually schedule something for the
morning the coffee or late evening so if
you're not on my newsletter list I'd
suggest you get on everything's free I'm
not really selling stuff on there and
hopefully when it come to your city will
be able to meet next Amanda the most
pressing question is do search for
[ __ ] are independent publisher I find
the most don t NT his part is not the
writing itself but how to get it
published look forward to your thoughts
in your future book so this is an
interesting question how I went through
it was I had an agent who then found a
literary agent they're two different
things my main agent books me in at
corporate gigs and speaking gigs and a
bunch of brand deals where he is not the
literary agent that's a totally
different person and her role is to line
up deals with publishers and be the
interface between me and them answer any
questions who that relationships that
kind of stuff I think it depends on what
your big goal is if your goal is just to
have a book and you don't even need a
publisher you don't need an agent if
it's just to be able to have something
that you can sell our conferences or
show your grandkids or just something
that you have on your to-do list bucket
list and you want to check off then just
do it yourself it's a lot simpler if you
want it to go big then for me I want to
bring a publisher on board I know what
I'm good at I know what I'm not good at
I need help in some areas and I want to
partner with the right publisher to help
me do that and so that's your goal then
I would definitely look at publishers
and I would say go with an agent they
will take a cut of whatever deal they
bring in but they do all the negotiating
for you and they have the contact so in
my case with my publisher we had a whole
bunch of publisher deals basically lined
up back to back to back calls really
like one call hang out onto another call
hang up on to another call with
different publishers for me to
understand them for them to understand
me and then for them to put in offers
and the way that she structured it was
basically like a when you're selling a
house you want to create a bidding war
and she created a bidding war between
three or four different publishers ended
up increasing the offer twice from the
one that I end up going with so she more
than paid for for her Commission on that
one and so I think it'd be worthwhile
going to a an agent if they're willing
to represent you and building up from
there on the same token I would say try
to build your own community one thing
that helped me get in so quickly and get
a sizable advance is that I have a
community right I have a YouTube
audience I have a Twitter islands I have
a news
letter list I have a popular website so
start now and building up that community
especially those first-time authors it's
hard to get any kind of advanced
especially a sizable one because they're
relying on you to sell it and they don't
believe that you can sell because you
don't have a community so the more you
can start building that up right now the
Morlock you'll have and getting deals
and publishers fill up dear Evan CN team
let me know when and where I can buy the
book k we got it Philip it's going to be
a little while a year plus probably but
as soon as it comes out I will let you
guys know so you can pick it up I
appreciate the support nikhil i hope i
pronounced that okay evan is the book
available in ebook format and when are
you coming to India is it released in
india too i'm assuming it's going to be
released in ebook format I don't know
exactly that part of things yet the way
that books are normally released is it
comes out in hardcover then softcover I
don't know if that's the plan again
right now all in focus on is writing and
giving them the book and then we're
going to worry about the formatting and
how to release it it will definitely be
available in India I hope maybe I can
come to Indiana tour I haven't been
India her lots of great things excited
to come and hopefully meet you guys and
ebook I'm assuming it will be and as
soon as I know details and all that I
will let you guys know Adrian I want to
be your first buyer would you write a
dedication note on it let me know when
it comes out are you going to include
any exercises for reflection action
thank you love you Jen Adrian this is a
really cool question I would love to
find out ways to be able to incorporate
you guys and make things personal I love
my YouTube community i love my audience
I obviously love helping entrepreneurs
as much as I can sign books make it
dedication meet with you talk about your
company what you're trying to do I want
to make that available I'm not exactly
sure what the format's going to be I'm
totally open to ideas whether it's you
in a book tour whether it's doing
something online and signing copies is
handing them out let me know what you
think again I'm not in book marketing
mode yet that will come later so
whatever ideas you have leave in the
comments and
I will save them for future reference in
terms of exercises and reflection
there's a lot that you have to think
about there's a lot of theory and ideas
and then there's how I've applied them
to have success in my businesses and
then is how others have applied them to
and I think with each section of the
book you'll have a lot to think about
and reflect on and I also want to be a
part of you realizing that success so
not just thinking about it but then
taking action and moving forward with
your company and again I'm not exactly
sure the format how that might work if
we're doing Google Hangouts Twitter
chats email youtube videos whatever
makes sense I'm open to ideas again so
let me know leave it in the comments and
I'll of gentoo she's great Harley love
you're stuck when I don't get the
hashtag thing words have meanings how
does adding the hashtag give it a bigger
meaning to me having hashtags in the
book feels like it's going to seem so 20
teams in the 20s 30s perhaps because
it's already seen as sort of gimmicky to
me wow admittedly I generally don't get
the social media thing Harley ah I
totally get where you're coming from at
first I didn't really understand the
hashtag thing either I thought it was
gimmicky I thought it was something just
for teens but I've come to grow and
appreciate it and love it and I just
like it you know I see it as a symbol
you look at semiotic it's a study of
things that stand for something else
it's more than just a word it's a
movement ideally it represents a
collection of thoughts at least to me so
you know the word believe you can look
it up in the dictionary and it has a
certain meaning they may have multiple
meanings for me when I use hashtag
believe that means something concrete to
me that's about believe in to what
you're doing that's about believing in
yourself and also believe that it's
going to work out and so when I use
hashtag believe and I always have a
capital V with it too hashtag capital
believe it represents something more to
me than just seeing the word believe in
a normal sentence I don't that makes
sense I think it's something that who
can rally people around it's a concept
it helps describe what you're doing more
than
just a single word can i feel like if
you look at pictures especially on
instagram and also on Twitter worth
hashtag culture is built in they become
search terms they become things people
are looking for and it becomes a way
that again it allows it to stand for
something more than just a singular
definition of that word I hope that
helps and for those watching if you're
using hashtags I'd love to know your
thoughts as well because I definitely
feel where Harley's coming from and I
also i love this is it really
interesting I love Harley the
self-awareness that you have I love that
you're expressing maybe not hate maybe
displeasure maybe uncertainty you're not
you don't you don't understand it but
instead of coming in and hating on and
say there's a stupid idea you come out
with your views and also admit that you
don't know much about social media and
you don't get it and so you're trying to
seek to understand and I really
appreciate that I think quite often
people have different views on things
and they just lash out and you see them
off and on YouTube and social media
haters just haters going to hate the
hate on things without seeking to
understand and you're doing the opposite
do understanding you're trying to find a
solution so I really appreciate that and
the way you wrote that comment next up
Sam I'm interested to know your views on
taking salary work while trying to be an
entrepreneur our current predicament has
me in a position and I feel so financial
necessity I feel out of integrity is it
normal to feel like this I feel like I
need to give myself some breathing room
in order to be able to see beyond the
financial strain as it blinds my vision
significantly am I still in integrity as
long as I still have my entrepreneurial
goals in check same great question i
feel like it did an answer on this on a
recent blab but I'm not the guy who says
you have to go all in on
entrepreneurship I think too many people
do that I think people quit their jobs
invest their life savings into a company
and then 36 months later they're back
looking for another job I don't think
you need to burn the boats and burn the
bridges I think it's okay to start
part-time I think the biggest thing is
making sure that you still do something
every single data
your company right it can be hard when
you have a typical job then still find
time between that and your family and
your hobbies and your friends and other
responsibilities to focus on your
business where I would schedule it out
at least 30 to 60 minutes every single
day on your business on top of that I'd
also take a job not just at a financial
necessity but also to learn I would try
to get a job where I could learn
something that would help me in my
future business or in my current
business that I'm doing on the side
something we're going to not just make
money but make contacts get education
potentially get some new clients or what
I'm doing on the side get as close to
the entrepreneur founder as possible
take on projects work for a small
company 10 people or less that you look
up to and respect that you want to be
like in a few years that's the kind of
job that I would look for not just one
that pays me money next up Nikki haven't
I really need your help what advice you
have for a person in high school who is
trying to become a youtuber great
question number one is just start I
think people whatever idea you have
whatever business you two were otherwise
people just don't start you try to plan
plan plan plan and never actually do and
it's great that you're reaching out and
asking questions just start thinking
about what you're passionate about
thinking about what message you want to
share i'm making this video off my ipad
i'm walking the whole foods it's raining
there's a ton of noise behind me i'm a
guy with 130,000 subs on my channel and
i'm making this video with an ipad it's
not about the gears about the content so
you can just start to understand that
your first attempts will suck you'll
hate them you look at them and you won't
want to publish them that's okay keep
going don't compare yourself to the
biggest greats that are having huge
success right now just compare yourself
to how you were doing yesterday as long
as you're getting better every single
day that's what counts post it ups are
gains on track and circuit in momentum
the first time you try anything you're
gonna suck at it this will be no
different so that's okay they stuck the
suck and then just keep going and then
three I would look to model success I
would look at youtubers that you do look
up to not that you're comparing your
talents to them but look at things they
do look at how they shoot things look at
the top of the cover look at how they
answer questions look at how they do on
boxing's or whatever it is that you're
going to do on your channel model
success find channels that inspire you
that make you be the best version of
yourself that push you out of your
comfort
don't to go and do this when people
around you your family friends may not
believe in what you're doing well you
may not believe in yourself enough to
keep going find those channels that
inspire you watch those every day to
keep you motivated to keep going do
those three things and you'll have
success and let me know what your
channel is when it comes out I'm excited
to watch it to Peter hi Evan I want to
becoming an entrepreneur one day you
told me to do what I love the problem is
I don't love that much now I'm stuck I
can't find out what business i should
start on the other hand i really want to
be an entrepreneur do you have a
solution our way to work this out and
love to hear from you haven't Peter
super common question yes you need to
start a business run something you're
passionate about don't just do it for
the money you do that you're going to
fail it's the fastest way to bankruptcy
you got to do something that you're
passionate about that really helps
people and the more you help people the
more you do stuff that makes you come
alive the more value going to provide
the money you're going to make it if you
don't know what your passion is the
short answers explore try a bunch of
stuff you want to do something until you
find something that makes you come alive
so say yes the things try a whole bunch
of different things that may not even
make sense in your head you're just
saying yes to opportunities until you
find the one thing that makes you come
alive and I've told this example before
a couple times but for me it was salsa
dancing as an example I told my business
to know what I want to do next and I was
looking for a business opportunity i
joined the salsa company as a dancer
just taking lessons without making it
feel like i had to find my next business
opportunity because if i walked in to
that salsa class i have everything on
paper that works against me I'm too tall
I don't speak the language I don't
understand Spanish you know I've never
heard tell soon as it before I can't
dance on V my arms are getting really
tired from holding his ipod it's a good
exercise think we're getting like closer
and closer and closer because I can't
hold it up far but I went to the class
without the expectations of it having to
be my next business opportunity and I
fell in love with it and you know
ten-plus years later I'm an investor in
a salsa dancing company one of the
largest in North America I'll spend 20
plus hours a week in that business and
dancing I'll DJ I'll teach I have a lot
of fun with this become a big part of my
life I met my wife Nina through dancing
and if I had just gone to that first
class looking for my next opportunity I
would have killed that idea because of
all the reasons why I did look good on
paper but I fell in love with it and so
that's the key try a bunch of things see
what you fall in love with see what
makes you come alive and when you find
that thing then look at how can I turn
this into a business opportunity next
lead looking forward to Evan when you
launch your book Thank You Lee I think
Jen will be a godsend for you help when
you bring your book intuition good luck
yeah i agree Jen's been a huge help gr
eyes has been a huge help my agent has
been a huge help this is definitely a
team effort any important project guys
that's important to you that can have
huge impact share your vision bring on a
team because you can't do it alone and
if you try it's never going to reach its
full potential because you are great at
some things and suck at other things and
instead of focusing on what you suck at
excel at what your great ad and delegate
the rest of people who love doing all
those other things Peter hope to see you
in the Netherlands Ivan I'm excited to
come to the Netherlands also never been
there one of my first team members a
dese lives in another lens and so I owe
him a visit and if i come there with the
book i will come to see you too Peter
looking forward to it last question
dread dog loyal fan of the channel how
do you find a team of like-minded people
who share the same values and goals to
collaborate with thanks to this video
I'm really looking forward to your book
hashtag believe find that team is super
challenging and one of the hardest and
most important things that you have to
do for your business I think it comes
from a couple things I think it comes
from one standing for something you know
what do you what is your business here
to do besides make money what are you
staying for is a human being what's the
positive impact that you want to try to
make in the world because that's what
attracts team you know since she's an
entrepreneur you're not going to be able
to pay the most amount of money to
somebody to come and join your team if
people were in it just for the money
they go work at a big company they can
offer much bigger pain much better
benefits they come because they love
what you're trying to do they love the
impact that you're trying to create and
so you need to understand what that is
right if they can't tell the difference
between you and every other company and
forget it you're not going to get the
best people to you have to make that
really clear right put it in your
marketing put on your website put it in
your job description when I look to hire
people for my team my arms are getting
so tired bringing them in this is a good
workout I should make these videos
longer just to
build up my arms when I look at building
my team the first paragraph of the job
description is always about believe and
what we stand for as a business and that
turns off a lot of people people look at
that and say this is really stupid
believe in entrepreneurs you know how
much does this pay and that's great
because those guys self eliminate
anybody who thinks that your mission is
stupid you don't want to deal with right
you don't even want to interview them
you don't want them to waste your time
and you don't want them to waste their
time either on the other hand other
people look at that they see that
message and they love it and they can't
wait to subscribe they can't wait to be
a part of your community they can't wait
to send in the job application and so
you have to be really clear with your
job descriptions and with all of your
marketing you watch my youtube videos
you go to my website you follow me on
Twitter you see that I'm all about
believing in entrepreneurs it loses out
of everything that I do and as a result
I start attracting other people who
believe in entrepreneurs if you look at
that youtube comments as an example most
of the YouTube comments I get aa took
that shot to the eye most of the YouTube
comments that I get are really positive
and I think we have a really special
community here that most YouTube
channels don't get and I get a lot of
comments from you guys saying this is
one of the best places on YouTube for
the comments in the community that's
because of the message right that
doesn't happen by accident we don't get
an insane number of haters that's by
design and so you want to create that
community right you want to attract
people who believe the same thing that
you are believing because you're putting
out a powerful positive
message I get people every day who write
into me you want to do some kind of
collaboration they see the videos they
read my newsletter they follow me on
Twitter they want to do some kind of
collaboration together because i like my
message and so for you the key is one
having a message and then to clearly
articulating that message in every
single communication piece that you put
out so you can attract the right team to
your business oh I talked a lot throats
hurting arms getting tired raining the I
love you guys next week give me some
questions not so many but leave comments
I always appreciate it and I'll answer
them let me know what you think back to
the top let me know what your big goal
is a numerical that you're trying to
force yourself to quote an achieve that
will stretch yourself and if you have
questions about my book about the book
writing process or anything else have we
talked about today leave it in the
comments below and I will do my best to
answer thank you guys have an amazing
day I'll talk to you soon